I was thinking today and I wanted to ask
you about this because it it only
occurred to me much later but we went
through and and are still going through
the the whole metoo movement and then I
realized nine to five which is 1980 one
of my favorite movies of all time okay
yeah and and for good for good reason
yeah nine to five I want to say it's
1980 yes that movie is dealing with
sexual harassment
and that movie is maybe 30 years ahead
of its time because there's a period of
time and you can still see it you can
see these movies were sexually harassing
women is kind of a joke yeah you know
the guy in the office chasing the
assistant around the desk yeah it has a
quaintness the way people that drank too
much used to have acquaintance but today
you see it very differently you know and
it looks very different now there were
comedians like Foster Brooks her's
entire career was I'm drunk and and Dean
Martin and now we have a different view
of that it doesn't immediately seem like
a knee slapper to us the boss sexually
harassing women in the office who work
for him you guys made a movie about it
that was a massive hit and it was
talking about something I think up to
that point had not been no one had
really shown a light on it I don't think
or wage theft or guys being trained by a
woman who knows the business better than
anybody and being promoted right past
her
all those kinds of things I mean they're
all still out there in the workforce I
mean the situation for people who work
in offices today in a way is worse
because now
those three women wouldn't even know who
their boss was probably would never meet
him face to face right they're hired by
a contracting company that contracts
them out to another company and so who
do you go to when something who do you
complain to you know and then with
computers which we didn't have then you
can be so easily spied on it's it's
really hard I mean we would the three of
us probably would have had two or three
jobs yeah in order to be able to afford
the lifestyle that you saw us living at
that time you talked about I know you're
talking about Lily but Dolly Parton you
bonded with her yes while making that
film she is an amazing woman she is
amazing she is so smart and she's kind
of psychic she's really profound I I'm
in awe of Dolly I love her very much and
she gave you advice because you had seen
your father's reaction to fame
if someone came up to Henry fond and won
an autograph he was terrified he would
run
well more weekends with me and my
brother when he would come and visit us
because he and my mother were separated
he would take us to Rye New York and he
would take us there and I'll never
forget a woman came and asked for his
autograph and he ran and he was in bad
mood all day it ruined the whole thing
for us he hated it he he I mean I don't
know why but he just hated it and I was
with Dolly we went on the road she was
so grateful for me casting her in the
movie nine to five and I Was preparing
to do a story of a hillbilly illiterate
Woman based on a book called the doll
maker and I needed to go there and meet
those people and Dolly I said to her
you're the only hillbilly I know
Dolly Parton and she's
cool yeah I want I said you know I want
to meet somebody who lives in in a
holler with no electricity or anything
so so I can kind of flesh out my
character I went to Nashville I stayed
with her and her husband
Carl that was an experience in her house
Carl cooked us breakfast I said how did
you two meet and he described the first
time he saw her he was driving a truck
past a 7-Eleven and there she was in the
parking lot drinking a Crown Cola and he
he he was just sitting at The Breakfast
Table he said no you don't understand it
was like what and he fell over backwards
now that is love
describing how you met your wife
handsome man boy I sang back up for
Dolly in the at the Grand old Opry oh my
God and anyway
she put me on her tour bus with three or
four friends of hers and we spent 10
days touring
Appalachia Missouri the Ozarks Arkansas
and I ended up meeting somebody that I
went back and lived with and chopped
their wood and built their cow and so on
and so forth so we here we were on the
road in the back hollers you know with
people who lived in tar paper Shacks
Dolly and it was her tour bus and she
was had the stateroom at the end I never
saw her not looking a hundred percent
Dolly Parton the wig the whole thing
going to see these people she presented
herself just like they hoped she would
and I thought yeah
that's how to do it you've got to love
those people who like you yes yeah yeah
and oh boy does she have fans and she
just loves them and appreciates them and
she taught me she taught me a lot she
didn't say anything does she show by
example she showed by example yeah it's
funny when I was very young and I would
meet one of my heroes which would happen
occasionally
I remember the feeling in my case it was
John Candy and I was I would have been
17. how old would I have been I would
have been about 20 or 20 years old maybe
and I was in college and I met John
Candy and he was one of my comedy Heroes
and I was nervous about meeting him
because I thought well sometimes you run
into a famous person and they're cold
they're not who you thought they were
and he was everything I could have
wanted him to be times ten and I
remember to this day the joy that gave
me
that what he was demonstrating to me was
it's real I really am that person that
you like and that has stayed with me
forever I've always wanted to be that
way good for you if anybody if I run
into anybody anywhere
I want them to know that they're uh that
it's okay if you thought it was that
person and you liked me for that reason
I am that person and if it means that we
sit and talk for 15 minutes then we do
yeah so and it's so so cool I'm glad
that you found your way yeah to I mean
I'm thinking about your dad in the
selfie era
do you think he hated an autograph oh my
God
what's that TMZ TMZ Henry Henry you know
yeah that wouldn't have gone too well
yeah